foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar biopharma
101 analysis of adeno-associated virus
vectors
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by psyx
to learn more visit cyx.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Stephen calciano Market development
manager biopharma CE at psyx and Paula
orange market development manager
biopharma Ms at psyx Stephen Paula you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to biopharma
101 analysis of adeno-associated virus
vectors my name is Stephen and I'm a
market development manager here at psyx
I'm joined by my colleague Paula orange
and together we're going to be providing
an overview of aav based gene therapy
characterization workflows
before we dive into the adeno-associated
viral Vector analysis workflows let's
take a moment to discuss the background
of aav its components of Interest a
typical aav manufacturing process as
well as its Associated analytical
challenges
AV is the short name for a dental
Associated virus it's also one of the
most widely used delivery vehicles in
gene therapy due to its
non-pathogenicity low immunogenicity and
Broad tropism to infect multiple cell
types
this feature makes aav particularly
interesting for a variety of genetic
disease indications as the capsid can be
tailored toward the specific cell type
in Vivo
adeno-associated virus is an icosahedral
virus with a protein shell referred to
as a capsid that is assembled of three
viral proteins named vp1 vp2 and vp3 in
an ideal ratio of 1 to 1 to 10.
let's take a look at the wild type aav
genome it contains two itrs a rep Gene a
cap Gene and a polya signal
the entire genome size is around 4.7 KB
each of these components plays a role in
the AV multiplication and incorporation
into the host cell genome
the ITR or inverted terminal repeat
sequence comprises 145 bases each it's
an important for aav multiplication in
capsidation and integration into the
host cell genome
the rep Gene encodes four proteins with
overlapping sequences
they're required for Gene regulation and
replication of the aav
the cap Gene encodes three capsid
proteins vp1 vp2 and vp3 with a
molecular weight of 87 72 and 62
kilodaltons in a non-structural protein
named AAP or assembly activating protein
the aav capsid is composed of a mixture
of these three proteins totaling 60
monomers arranged in an icosahedral
symmetry in the ideal ratio of 1 to 1 to
10 with an estimated size of 3.9 Mega
Daltons AAP is essential for the capsid
assembly process
and the poly a tail is you is used for
the polyadenylation signal
now let's take a look at the recombinant
aav genome in the recombinant aav genome
we still have two itrs but the rep Gene
and cap Gene have been replaced by a
transgene and a promoter region that
regulates the transgene expression
the transgene is also called the
therapeutic Gene depending on the size
of the transgene
the intact genome size for a recombinant
aav can be anywhere from about two
kilobases to 5 kilobases
since there is no rep and caption in the
recombinant aav genome the recombinant
aav can't replicate by itself
that is a very important safety feature
for recombinant aav based Therapeutics
this slide shows the three plasmid
system for making recombinant aav also
known as the triple transfection system
as I mentioned earlier the recombinant
aav genome does not contain the cap and
rep Gene it is replication deficient
in order to make more virons or viral
particles we need three plasmids the
first plasmid contains the entire
recombinant aav genome including the
transgene
the second helperplasmid provides the
rect Gene and the capsid
the third plasmid provides the aav
derived genes that are essential for the
replication of the virus
after the packaging host cell is
transfected with these plasmids the host
cell can make recombinant aav virons
this slide shows the typical
manufacturing and purification process
of recombinant aav at a small scale
first the host cells are transfected
with three aav plasmid system
the host cells will make recombinant aav
then the cells are harvested by
centrifugation
after the cells are resuspended they are
lysed by sonication
then the host cell genome and plasmid
DNA are digested with nuclease
the clarified lysate is loaded for
ultrasonification and the contents of
the clarified lysate will separate to
different layers where the recombinant
aav can be removed
is it purified by chromatography and
buffer exchanged to the final
formulation buffer
recombinant aav based Gene therapies
represent an analytical challenge
through the complexity associated with
various genome sizes
serotypes and Sample heterogeneity
associated with the empty and partially
filled capsids and small size impurities
present in the sample
biopharma scientists often use multiple
platforms to assess a variety of
critical quality attributes however each
platform does have its own inherent
limitations
all in all comprehensive
adeno-associated virus analysis is time
consuming and establishing robust
analytical methods early in development
is required to ensure the success of aav
based product development
here we see a list of aav quality
considerations and their related impacts
to gene therapy drug potency
immunogenicity transduction efficiency
and packaging efficiency
often these quality considerations are
deemed as critical quality attributes
that must be monitored throughout the
aav based gene therapy development
process to ensure the safety and the
efficacy of the product
for example the viral protein profile
has been shown to indicate Vector
potency immunogenicity transduction
efficiency and packaging efficiency
The genome Integrity aav titer full and
empty capsid ratio all influence Vector
potency immunogenicity and transduction
efficiency
Additionally the presence of protein or
nucleic acid impurities impacts the
vector potency and immunogenicity of the
therapy
now that we've taken a look at the
background of aav based Therapeutics and
the related manufacturing workflows
let's overview the key analytical
workflows for aav-based Gene therapies
that we'll be discussing in the next
section of this presentation
the first part of this presentation will
focus on capillary electrophoresis based
methods here we'll discuss viral protein
monitoring which includes a quantitative
ratio assessment of the capsid proteins
and related protein impurities
additionally we'll discuss genome
integrity and this assay analyzes the
encapsidated transgene quality as well
as residual process related nucleic
acids as well as a workflow to calculate
the full to empty capsid ratio
then we'll conclude with lcms based
workflows for aav structural
characterization at both the intact and
the peptide level
our first analytical workflow helps to
better understand capsid protein quality
through determination of the viral
protein ratio
as well as providing the ability to
screen samples for protein impurities
with very high resolution
Purity assessment of adeno-associated
virus is important to ensure the quality
and safety of all aav based products
also it's important to have high
sensitivity detection to enable analysis
of low tighter samples as is common When
developing the manufacturing process and
scaling up during development
the key workflow we'll discuss in this
next section is capillary
electrophoresis using sodium
dodecosulfate with laser-induced
fluorescence detection
the acronym used for this workflow is
c-e-s-d-s-l-i-f
it's important to understand how
cesdslif compares to other protein
analysis methodologies so in this slide
we will review two analysis techniques
which are common in the industry
SDS page and reversed phase high
performance liquid chromatography
on the left we can see an example image
from a manually prepared SDS page gel
with a protein standard ladder on the
far left side of the image and eight aav
samples analyzed in the lanes labeled
one through eight
while separation is achieved with this
SDS page gel these assays suffer from
lack of precision poor quantitative
performance and user-to-user variability
on the right side of this slide we can
see two example chromatograms generated
using reversed phase chromatography
this separation is based on retention of
the various viral protein capsids with
the Aleutian order and a resolution
being a function of hydrophobicity of
the sample components
this results in illusion order changes
depending on the particular aav
stereotype used
we can see aav stereotype a on the top
chromatogram shows vp2 then vp3 then vp1
in the chromatogram illusion order while
the aav serotype B shows vp2 followed by
vp1 then vp3
this changing illusion order makes it a
requirement to redevelop methods for
each development program depending on
the serotype and precludes the ability
to generate platform separation methods
Additionally the resolution between
viral capsid proteins is non-optimal as
we can see some Coalition especially in
serotype b
at a high level capillary
electrophoresis is the application of
traditional slab gel electrophoresis or
SDS page in a capillary using linear
polymers in a solution to create a
molecular sieve
this allows molecules that have a
similar charge to size ratio to be
resolved by hydrodynamic size
the separation is based on the analyte's
differential migration through the gel
Matrix and is solely based on
hydrodynamic size differences
however to characterize by molecular
mass the same charge on all proteins is
required
this is achieved through the use of an
anionic detergent sodium dodex sulfate
which complexes with proteins at a
constant ratio of 1 to 1.4
in addition reducing reagents like betum
or capoethanol can be introduced to the
sample to reduce disulfide bonds and
further denature the protein
upon the application of voltage the
proteins migrate through the gel Matrix
with the similar proteins migrating
quickest and the larger proteins
migrating more slowly
the CE SDS workflow for viral capsid
proteins starts with a sample
pre-treatment protocol to denature the
viral capsid into its substituent
protein components as we mentioned which
are vp1 vp2 and vp3
for UV based detection this is
accomplished by diluting the AAP sample
with an incubation buffer of 100
millimolar Tris HCL at pH 9 with 1 SDS
and two beta mercapoethanol at elevated
temperatures for 10 minutes
samples are then diluted with water and
subsequently analyzed by CE
for high sensitivity detection with
laser-induced fluorescence samples are
denatured with the same incubation
buffer in the presence of dtt and
chromio p503 dye which tags a protein
and enables fluorescence-based detection
once the voltage is applied the viral
proteins migrate through the gel Matrix
with the proteins migrating in the order
of increasing size
an example electropherogram is shown on
the right side of the slide capillary
electrophoresis provides high resolution
separation and enables detection of all
three viral proteins as well as a
closely related protein impurity labeled
in the graph as vp3 Prime
one of the major advantages to capillary
electrophoresis for a viral protein
profiling is its ability to provide a
platform approach to analyzing aavs
capillary gel electrophoresis is based
on the principle of a high resolution
size based separation and can analyze
multiple aav serotypes without requiring
intensive method development
the electropherogram shown in this slide
demonstrate that multiple aav cell types
including aav1 aav2 and aav8 can all be
analyzed with high resolution in a
serotype independent manner
this workflow also enables accurate
capsid protein tighter determination
in this example we can see a Serial
dilution of an aav capsid protein sample
with known titer the method demonstrates
good linearity with an r-squared value
of 0.997 and a limit of quantitation of
6.4 e to the 9 GC per ml
running an unknown sample against this
calibration curve can serve as a
reliable method to determine protein
tighter especially from low
concentration samples
this protein tighter data can be used to
determine the full to empty product
ratio when combined with the genome
Integrity data we'll cover in the next
section
The genome Integrity workflow is used to
characterize the Integrity of the
encapsidated genomic material in the aav
capsid as well as screen aav samples for
process related nucleic acid impurities
this is an important method because the
quality of the encapsidated genome
inside a viral Vector impacts the
infectivity efficacy and safety of the
gene therapy
there are many ways in which a transgene
in the genome cassette can be produced
including a missing or not present
transgene resulting in an empty or
partial capsid
a truncated transgene or a capsid
containing contaminant fragments from
the host cell or process plasmids
the key workflow we will discuss in this
sanction is capillary gel
electrophoresis with laser-induced
fluorescence also called c g e l i f
there are two sample pre-treatment
workflows compatible with the genome
Integrity assay
the first workflow depicted in the graph
at the top of the slide
is used for analyzing the encapsinated
genomic material only
in that assay we take the aav sample and
treat it with nuclease to remove the
nucleic acids outside of the protein
capsids
then we treat the sample with protease
and perform a nucleic acid extraction
using a PCR prep kit
to analyze a nucleic acid components
both encapsulated in the viral particle
as well as the process-related host cell
impurities like host cell DNA and RNA we
can go directly to the nucleic acid
extraction workflow with the PCR prep
kit and then analyze with capillary gel
electrophoresis
now let's take a look at a sample
electropherogram to give you an idea of
what you can expect when running high
resolution genome Integrity analysis via
capillary gel electrophoresis
in this electropherogram starting at the
left you could see a grouping of various
process and product related impurities
the first initial hump is related to
host cell DNA and host cell RNA as
indicated by the two first arrows on the
left
in the middle again based on size
separation we can see partial genome or
contaminant fragments that were released
from the capsid including a partial
capsid with a truncated Gene as well as
a capsid which had contained a
contaminant fragment
all the way on the right side of the
electropherogram we can see the single
stranded DNA with the target therapeutic
Gene in the nice sharp Peak with an
intact genome size estimated at 2.4
kilobases
when running a standard ladder against
the standard it's easy to estimate the
size of the intact genome Peak and
confirm the identity of your full length
genome material
here we can see another example of
running two different aav
samples with two different encapsidated
genomes the first sample is an aav
serotype 2 containing the lacz gene we
can see the profile similar to what we
saw in the previous slide where we have
fault small size impurities related to
host cell DNA and RNA a partial genome
and the intact Genome of the Lac Z Gene
at 4.7 kilobases in the blue Trace
in the green Trace we can see the same
aav2 serotype with the gfp genome
encapsulated we see the same
characteristic Trace with small size
process related impurities the partial
genome material in a smaller size intact
genome Peak estimated at 2.4 kilobases
here in the bottom we can see an example
RNA ladder this is an ssrna ladder which
can be used to calibrate and estimate
the size of the genes in the first two
samples it's important to note that when
doing this the RNA letter is single
stranded RNA but from aav our intact
genome and encapsulated genome are all
SS single strand DNA so it's important
to provide a correction factor to
accommodate for the slight change in
migration time but when applied this
workflow can provide an easy way to
estimate the size of your intact genome
Peak
similar to how our viral protein
profiling assay was serotype independent
The genome Integrity assay to assess the
Integrity of the encapsulated genomic
material is also serotype independent
here is an example of a high throughput
serotype independent workflow exhibiting
four different aav serotypes including
aav9 in pink aav8 and dark blue aav5 in
light blue and aav2 in green we can see
characteristic profiles of the
impurities both process and partial
product related impurities
uh and the sharp Peaks for the intact
genome all at around four uh upwards of
four kilobases as reported by the um
standard letter
following the same idea that we saw with
the viral protein tighter assay we can
also use capillary electrophoresis to
assess the genome titer of our aav
sample so here we can see the separation
of aav genome extracted from serial
diluted standards with known titer so
we've created an eight-point calibration
curve and plotted corrected Peak area
versus aav titer reported in GC per ml
we can see excellent linearity from this
calibration curve with an r squared
value of 0.9967 and a reported limit of
detection of 1.28 e to the 10 GC per ML
and the limit of quantitation of 2.56 e
to the 10 GC per amount making this as a
applicable to running lower
concentration samples that you may
encounter during process optimization
and development
the final ce-based application that
we'll discuss is full and empty capsid
ratio monitoring to analyze the
assembled drug substance
here we'll discuss how full capsids
deliver intact transgene into Target
cells and full capsids directly impact
the potency of aav based Therapeutics so
monitoring the full and empty capsid
ratio is important during process
optimization to remove empty and partial
capsids for better efficacy during your
process development and ensure the
safety of your aav based gene therapy
uh this workflow is not another analysis
um analytical workflow from the
separation but in this case we're going
to be calculating the empty to full
product ratio from protein and genome
tighter assays that we discussed in the
previous two workflows using those two
data sets to determine our full and
empty ratio
comprehensive analysis of aav critical
quality attributes can be achieved using
capillary electrophoresis on the left
side of this slide we see all of the
characteristics that our viral protein
characterization assay
c-e-s-t-s-l-i-f can enable including
viral protein profile and ratio
assessment of protein impurities and the
determination of any degradation of
viral capsid proteins this assay can
also determine our capsider on the right
hand side of the slide in green we have
our genome Integrity assay leveraging
capillary gel electrophoresis with
laser-induced fluorescence
this viral genome analysis enables a
quick workflow to assess our transgene
Purity and genome sizing estimation from
our small size you know Trend
encapsulated genomic material all the
way up to our full length Target genes
of about five kilobases
when we take our genome titer and divide
by our protein tighter we get a very
quick and easy way to assess the full
partial and empty ratio thus yielding a
novel approach for high resolution full
and empty aav capsid analysis
so now let's look at an example of
calculating the full capsid percentage
using this standard workflow
so for this example we've used an aav8
serotype 8 sample reference standard
from vijene and the value a was
determined from The genome Integrity
analysis assay using capillary gel
electrophoresis at 2.21 e to the 12 GC
per ml
value B was from the aav capsid analysis
workflow protein characterization
workflow using capillary
electrophoresis sodium dodecyl sulfite
laser-induced fluorescence with a value
reported of 2.65 e to the 12 GC per ml
so calculating you know dividing our
genome Tighter by our capsiditer in the
aav8 test sample we get a a value of
83.4 percent full capsin
comparing our value to Industry standard
techniques that are often a bit more
involved to use but often result in
reliable analytical results puts us
squarely between transmission electron
microscopy and analytical
ultrasonification
so I'd encourage you to take a look at
the vigine webinars if you have any
questions about how those data were
generated on tem and AUC but as you can
see the CE generated data from the
resultant calculation of viral protein
Tighter and genome tighter using
capillary gel electrophoresis results in
a value that is very consistent with the
industry standard techniques
now I would like to hand off the
presentation to my colleague Paula
orange who is going to take us through
some capsid protein characterization
workflows using liquid chromatography
Mass spectrometry
so thanks Paula over to you
thanks Steven for providing such a great
overview I am going to switch gears a
bit and focus on capsid proteins now
we've learned how to perform Purity
assessments with capillary
electrophoresis but we're going to take
a closer look at the VPS or viral
proteins because they are the primary
interface between the host and the
genetic material that we're trying to
deliver
now these proteins encapsulating that
genetic material are made up of three
VPS vp1 vp2 and bp3 they range in size
about a third to half the size of a
typical map but the kicker and one of
many is that they're derived from the
same genome through alternative splicing
meaning they share the same c-terminus
but they have different n Termini as you
can see depicted in this image below
by using intact Mass analysis with lcms
we can determine if they were expressed
properly we can confirm molecular weight
and compare it to the theoretical Mass
additionally we can use in-tech Mass
analysis to understand the overall
Integrity of the proteins provide an
overview of the modifications since the
proteins share quite a bit of sequence
and understand the protein impurities
then the next workflow will utilize to
characterize the VPS as peptide mapping
and here we'll be able to localize any
of those modifications and confirm the
sequence of the proteins remember we
only did molecular weight conformation
with intact Mass not primary sequence
conformation
some of the challenges associated with
aav sample analysis is the limited
sample quantity and the highly similar
sequence of the VPS and in turn highly
cynical highly similar physical
properties these similarities lead to
difficulties with separation associating
the modifications with the accurate VP
or basically just getting an accurate
hold of the sample so to combat these
some scientists will employ micro or
Nano LC to minimize the sample that's
utilized in separation or Implement ion
pairing agents like TFA or DFA but I'm
going to show you how we can avoid all
of those parameters
this is an overview or a nice schematic
providing the overview of the two
workflows that I'm going to focus on
today you can see following one will be
the intact Mass analysis workflow and
following number two we'll be following
the peptide mapping workflow now as I
started with intact Mass on the last
slide that's where we're going to begin
today
for the intact Mass analysis you can see
the sample sample preparation is fast
it's typically a denaturation step to
break the capsids apart maybe a buffer
exchange but that typically depends on
how you've stored or treated your sample
and sometimes if you are doing a buffer
exchange it's because you have to remove
the buffer so that it's not interfering
with the ionization on the mass spec but
in general we're using an LC Approach at
analytical flow rates coupled to an
accurate Mass system in this case it's
the xenotoft 7600 a qtop system and then
the data is going to be processed by
biologics Explorer which is a psychic
psyx processing software for you guessed
it processing biologics
like I said previously this experiment
is very simple there are no mobile phase
modifiers and we're sticking with
analytical flow making it simple and
easy to use plus there are no mobile
phase modifiers impacting the
sensitivity of the assay in this
experiment we're using generic aav2 not
therapeutic aav2 because we were just
establishing the workflow and the
genetic material wasn't of relevance
to solve the separation because we're
not using mobile phase modifiers we used
a specific deconvolution approach to
deconvolute scan by scan which helps to
identify all the proteins even when they
are colluding you can see on the left
hand side some of the VPS are colluding
so we have the ion map of the top Ms
data which is a nice way to see all the
VPS but also check for potential
impurities on the right hand side is the
time resolved deconvoluted data or TRD
which allows all of the acquired data
throughout the entirety of the
acquisition to be deconvoluted meaning
we're not only seeing information about
VPS but also potential other forms that
we might not have anticipated now this
approach means that there is very low
risk to missing proteins impurities even
when they're of low abundance
Gene Lee Bio from Louie has been working
on two different cell systems to
assemble their viral particles so we're
no longer looking at that generic aav2
from the last slide you can see on the
right those two different systems result
in different ratios of modifications on
the top layer we can see the three VP
derived the three viral proteins derived
from cell line sf9 which happens to be
an insect cell line and below is a human
cell line heck 293 and all of those
those three VPS associated with that
human cell line there is a significant
difference in the modification patterns
of the three VPS and this is known to
impact the quality of the virus and
cellular uptake so understanding these
differences and not missing any
potential protein impurities through a
comprehensive approach of analyzing the
data can and will be very helpful
looking deeper into the modifications
you can see a few acetylations
specifically on vp1 and vp3 of both cell
lines as well as phosphorylations and
phosphorylations are very similar in
Mass to sulfation and both modifications
can exist in aav samples so we wanted to
make sure that we were properly
identifying the modification
to confirm that we're looking at
phosphorylations samples were treated
with phosphatase and compared before and
after on the top on the right side we
have the before treatment depicted then
below that are the after treatment of
the three proteins now the Peaks which
were previously assigned to
phosphorylation are either gone or have
been significantly reduced which
confirms the phosphorylation Peak and
not a sulfated peak now we cannot
understand the exact localization of
that or any modification using this
approach especially not modifications
that will shift the mass by a very small
value so because of this we're going to
apply that second approach that I
introduced very briefly earlier of
peptide mapping
with peptide mapping we'll start by
denaturing the proteins to break them
break apart the capsids then the
proteins are reduced to break any
secondary structure bonds or holding the
the proteins together internally and
then it's alkylated to keep those bonds
from reforming lastly the proteins were
triptically digested to create a mixture
of peptides that we're going to separate
using lcms Ms again on the xenotoft 7600
system using analytical flow rate and
biologics Explorer to process the data
okay
peptide mapping can answer some
additional questions that cannot be
resolved by in-tech mass analysis for
instance we've already seen that the
molecular weight matches the theoretical
molecular weight but we haven't proven
the amino acid sequence matches the
theoretical amino acid sequence for
modifications we can understand exactly
where they are localized or located
especially for something like
deaminations which are incredibly
important for aav samples as it's been
shown that deamidated aavs can impact
the efficacy of the delivery and
deamidations have a very small mass
shift so it's almost impossible to
discern it at an intact level which is
why we're going to utilize peptide
mapping to do exactly that
let's start by looking at the sequence
information and one problem that I'm
going to come back to is the The Limited
protein sample in this case but first
what we can see here is that the primary
sequence of vp1 which is the largest of
the three proteins and it includes the
sequences of the P2 and bp3 now with
only a single triptych digestion and a
single injection we achieved about 95
sequence coverage even with the sample
being severely limited now to combat
that limited sample and very low
sensitivity or protein amount one option
would be to inject a lot of the sample
but these samples are typically quite
costly that's why they come in such
limited amounts
and then another method would be to use
micro or Nano LC but those systems are
difficult to maintain and it makes the
method development and deployment of the
method extremely complex
instead of deploying either of those
techniques we're using a xenotop 7600
which has the capability of xenotropping
but to make sure you have the generic
understanding of how a qtop system
typically works I've got this schematic
for you here and what I'm talking about
right now is called the duty cycle and
that is the percentage of ions that are
injected into the Toff region or the
flight tube but it's basically the
percentage of ions that are making it to
the detector
now with a generic cutoff instrument
there is a constant stream of ions being
passed through the quadrupole and into
the accelerator region but only a
portion of those ions will actually be
pulsed into the flight tube and that's
because the act of the top accelerator
is a non-constant action it pulses it
pushes which means that the rest of the
ions are lost and this is about a 5 to
25 percent duty cycle for your standard
qtop instrument meaning only 5 to 25
percent of ions are making it to the
detector whereas the rest of the ions
that we've worked so hard for with AVS
that are so limited only
75 or rather 75 percent of those ions
are being lost
with the xenotoft 7600 you can see that
we've employed or we've added these
Gates uh to allow us to have a trapping
technique that ensures a significantly
higher percentage of ions are being
delivered to the detector and it only
happens when necessary so for instance
if a peptide in very low abundance comes
through this region
xenotrapping will be engaged so the ions
are getting trapped by this xenogate and
the iq3 and they will only be released
once the top accelerator is ready to
push into the flight tube again
so they go from this trapped region
they're pushed into the accelerator and
then only then does the accelerator push
those ions into the flight tube so this
ensures a significantly better duty
cycle we're getting much closer to a
hundred percent if not achieving a
hundred percent of those ions getting to
the detector which is so important
especially in instances of aavs where
the sample is so severely limited and
that limited sample has many
modifications in very low abundance
what does the xenotrap look like when
engaged you ask uh think back earlier to
the in-tech mass analysis we confirmed
there were acetylated and phosphorylated
modifications on the VPS
and using peptide mapping we'll be able
to localize exactly where those
modifications occur this is typically
done using Collision induced Association
or CID and for some peptides this is a
very sufficient method we've got
comprehensive information to localize
the acetylation and phosphorylation even
in cases where there are multiple
positions that could carry the
modification it's great data quality
that is made possible by xenotropping
and CID together however there are
instances where ptms can be a lot more
challenging to elucidate using CID so
for this we have electron activated
dissociation or EAD
EAD is a tunable kinetic energy and a
novel fragmentation mechanism which
results in orthogonal fragmentation
patterns when compared to CID CID
produces B and Y fragments whereas EAD
produces C and Z fragments
and this is particularly important
during deamidation events to be able to
have this orthogonal fragmentation
because in many cases deamidation is
considered a critical quality attribute
or a cqa because deamidation in the
capsid capsid protein can affect the
viral uptake so they can also lead to
aspartate and isospartate formations and
there could be different forms in low
abundance other fragmentation techniques
cannot differentiate those different
isobaric amino acids like eadkin EAD can
produce specific fragments which allow
for differentiation of those isobaric
amino acids and the difference on the
side chain of these amino acids can even
lead to different behavior in the
protein so it's very important to
understand where there is an aspartate
versus an isospartate and we can see EAD
produces those C and Z fragments rather
than that being my ions like I said and
with EAD we are identifying these
diagnostic fragments of Z minus 44 for
identifying aspartate amino acids and Z
minus 57 to identify isospartate
in the interest of time I won't go into
any more detail I know I can speak about
this topic for days and I'm sure Steven
is is quite the same but I will quickly
reiterate the different workflows that
you can Implement across capillary
electrophoresis and mass spectrometry
platforms to characterize product and
process related impurities capsid
analysis genome Integrity full to empty
capsid ratios as well as determining the
Integrity of all VPS including
high-level information on modifications
and critical quality attributes
so feel free to reach out to Stephen or
I if you are interested in learning any
more about any of the workflows that
we've described in the last few minutes
but until then I want to thank you so
much for your time and I look forward to
hearing your questions thank you again
thank you Stephen and Paula for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
that you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right so let's get started our first
question is can the viral protein
profiling and genome Integrity workflows
using capillary gel electrophoresis be
used for in-process samples
yes hi Keely that's a that's a great
question and um well typically these
analysis techniques have been applied to
formulated samples we have had customers
employ these methods for in-process
analysis so especially when using the
laser-induced fluorescence detector with
p503 labeled capsid protein
you know there are some considerations
but it is possible to use these
workflows for in-process analysis
great thank you Stephen our next
question here is for Paula and this
question asks were any other deamidated
species identify identified excuse me by
Ms
absolutely uh so deamination is an
important quality attribute because it
affects the function of the aav
um so using EAD we also identified the
ylg peptide was deamidated in addition
to that twl peptide that I that I just
showed you
um and I'll say it's worth noting that
the order of Illusion for the Aspen ISO
ASP amino acids were opposite for the
two peptides so we can't rely solely on
the retention time to identify those
different isomers so EAD was a really
important functionality so that we could
identify that Z minus 44 and Z minus 57
to be able to diver
differentiate between the the isomers
great thanks Paula I have another
question here for Stephen this one asks
is it required to use the fluorescence
detector for aav analysis
so depending on the workflow it it may
be required so for the genome Integrity
assay
um we typically are using the laser and
for the protein
capsid assay we can use UV or the the
laser so it's just depending uh overall
the workflow is depending and the
detector options depend on the
sensitivity requirements for the assay
and we can share information about the
dynamic range of the assay and changes
based on the detector options that are
selected so not required by the help for
for when dealing with
um lower concentration samples
great thank you we've got some great
questions coming in from our audience
this next one here to what extent must
aav samples be purified beforehand prior
to being applied to the system I assume
using crude extract is not feasible
right
yeah so this is
um this is a good question I'm assuming
this is uh talking about capillary
electrophoresis but feel free to you
know correct me via the chat if I was
wrong but um so any of these samples you
know when analyzing
um
process related samples
um we have experience
using a buffer exchange workflow prior
to analysis where we either use diluted
formulation buffer or even undiluted
formulation buffer just depending on you
know if we're using the laser or not and
if we have enough signal from our sample
so but a quick buffer exchange into
formulation buffer is usually all that
we need in order to analyze the samples
by the viral protein or the genome
Integrity assay
great thank you Stephen Paula I have
another question coming your way this
question asks can you explain how the
samples were deconvoluted
cool okay
um so the TRD or uh time resolved
deconvolution activity node in biologics
Explorer is particularly suited to
accurately deconvolute components that
are poorly resolved chromatographically
by deconvoluting the data scan by scan
additionally unexpected low abundance
impurities which might not be visible as
peaks in the total ion chromatogram or
the TIC The Tick can be deconvoluted and
found leveraging those 3D plots that I
shared with you earlier while
traditional deconvolution approaches Ms
scans over a defined retention time
range are summed or averaged the
algorithm algorithm used for TRD enables
deconvolution of each tough Ms scan
across the retention time range
separately so information on
deconvoluted masses and the
corresponding retention times is
preserved and connected for all species
further enabling users to detect
expected alongside
unexpected species I find myself talking
with my hands a lot but you can't see me
so for this application the aav8 capsid
proteins extracted from that heck to
nine three and
um s f s F9 systems they were analyzed
using that TRD approach
great thank you Paula we do have a
question in here regarding getting a
copy of this webinar or a recording and
I want to mention that this webinar will
be available for on-demand viewing after
the live broadcast has ended today so
you can just click on the link that you
did to join in through the webinar and
re-watch it at any time after the
presentation
we have a few other questions in here so
we're going to go ahead and proceed this
next one is coming back to you Stephen
this asks do you need special software
to calculate the full and empty ratio of
aav
so that's a good question so for that
particular calculation you don't and the
reason I say that is because the CE
system software are going to be
providing reporting values for aav
capsider using that Viral protein
workflow and it's also going to be
providing the
um the genome titer for
um from The genome Integrity workflow so
those two results you do need the um the
capillary electrophoresis data
processing software however for the
empty the full to empty product ratio
it's you know just a simple division so
we're using Excel for that calculation
and it's you know very easy to get once
you've once you've
um you know used the system to generate
your protein and genome tighter
great thank you
we have one more question that we're
going to go ahead and wrap up with for
today and this last question asks do
samples need any pre-processing steps
prior to analysis by capillary
electrophoresis
yeah I think this is um you know similar
in a similar vein to the questions
regarding the in-process samples and
pre-treatment workflow so it's all
depending on where in the process the
samples are coming from and which
particular assay you're going to be
running so if it's the cesds viral
protein assay we will be you know there
there's um you know kits available for
um denaturing the proteins and labeling
them with fluorescence dye also for the
genome Integrity assay
um there are those two discrete
workflows that are available
the first one is for analyzing the
product related transgene only and
that's where we're enabling the use of
of nuclease
um and then doing a nucleic acid
extraction to get the the
um to analyze the trans Gene that's only
encapsidated into the aav particle and
then there's the other workflow which is
just going to be a a PCR prep workflow
essentially as a nucleic acid extraction
directly from the total aav sample and
that's where we can screen for our
process and product related samples so
yep there's always going to be a little
bit of pre-processing of these samples
but it's nothing too intensive and it's
um you know pretty easy to bring these
these techniques on site
great well thank you again Stephen and
Paula do you have any final comments for
our audience
yeah I would love to just let everybody
know that um in the next couple of weeks
we're going to take some deeper dives
into a few of these workflows
specifically
um so if you are interested in learning
more we are hosting our Master Class
Master Class live sessions which are
exactly what they sound like we're going
to be taking some of our experts
in-house and basically they'll be able
to provide a live demo so that you can
see exactly how the workflows are
performed start to finish so you can
look forward to those in a couple of
weeks I think we're even hosting one
next week
um and you can find them I think even
just by searching for for Master Class
live
thank you Kaylee
of course thank you we also would like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor psyx
for underwriting today's educational
webcast now before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you had
provided at the time of registration
as a reminder this webcast can be viewed
on demand and lab Roots will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye